let's head up the hill and you can see
kind of the other areas of the farm okay
oh carrots yep these carrots are pretty
close to ready yeah yeah
wow everything looks so incredible from
up here too it's like
this is where I feel like I would hang
out every day
how much space did you say this was uh
with the kind of house it's like 1.2
Acres okay yeah but I feel like you know
the average person doesn't need 1.2
acres to grow food for themselves or
their family right you can really kind
of fit a lot into a small space and so a
lot of what we do here is really
applicable to someone who's growing at
home
[Music]
I know that Eric is no stranger to the
heat so I'm just looking around and
trying to figure out how he deals with
this direct sun my friends like I was
mentioning at so Collective they really
want to lower the temperature yeah you
know they're getting kind of blasted
with heat you could fry an egg on there
on their soil right well actually the
thing that we're doing is using shade
cloths and I could show you on this bed
here
um so if you want to take a few they're
a little hot yeah
out there I feel like this is just
further driving the point home that it's
really very hot yeah I mean that's
interesting about shade is like
underneath that shade will be 20 degrees
cooler
I'll do these three
cool yeah I'll hold this shade cloth and
you can roll it out oh yay
you can just pull okay cool yeah
[Music]
and then we'll unfold it
up and over yeah perfect I was hoping we
would run under it like in elementary
army crawl maybe
when the plants like when they're
wilting in the afternoon sun
you know obviously it's not going to
kill them but a stop photosynthesizing
during that period and are actually
using up energy rather than creating it
so especially with like
you know younger plants that we
transplant in the shade really helps
with transplant shock nice yeah
transplant shock I feel like I got
transplant shock when I moved to LA I'm
sure I like this neat little row cover
it feels like we tucked him into bed and
yeah now we can play their lullaby seems
like you know such a simple solution to
making sure that your water isn't
evaporating straight out of your garden
buds as fast as you can put it in and
this is really accessible this is really
easy for the everyday person to use and
you could physically put your hand
underneath and feel how much cooler it
was just by adding that small structure
bye lettuce
[Music]